let's change gears here because there is
one rule change that is on the docket
for today we've been talking about it
all week and Chris look I am going to
claim credit on behalf of the show for
the discussion we had the other day
about the doughnut hole for the fourth
and 15 alternative to the onside kick if
you go ahead late in the game and
there's just a few seconds left and you
don't want to transfer possession to the
other team and give them a chance to win
it with a Stanford band type of a play
you can just go into the fourth and 15
formation get the ball to your
quarterback he runs around kills the
clock goes out of bounds game over
too bad the other team never gets the
ball and what we identified that's not
fair so you either have to be trailing
to use the fourth and 15 alternative or
it needs to be in on time down well the
proposal has been clarified / amended /
revised / flat-out changed to make it an
untimed down that was something you
suggested and and again barring any
evidence of the contrary we're claiming
credit for them realizing that that was
going to be a huge mistake if they
didn't have that caveat in there well
hopefully listen this is what shows like
this for where we are here to inform a
little bit we do follow the league like
two psychos and we're constantly texting
each other and on group text chains and
we talk and think about football all day
long so hopefully we did help somebody
out I really do hope so I mean again it
made no sense that first time around
you're right
you know a lot of teams I think you get
the ball there they're gonna take it and
go oh okay well we'll do what Patrick
mahomes did at the end of the Super Bowl
throw the ball right up in the air
here's the other thing Mike I want to
ask you about because I'm glad they
fixed that with the untime down what
about because I hear conversation about
this and I don't I don't agree with
everything I hear
but the fourth and 15 play if Patrick
mahomes throws a 70 yard bomb down the
middle of the field for a touchdown is
that going to be allowed we're gonna
keep it like a real no way right it's
okay good that's a play yeah the idea
the idea of saying okay you made it past
the 15 yards you get the ball 15 yards
from the play started no that's
incineration the saving discussion I
that the
rule is you get the ball fourth and 15
on the 25 as if you have the ball at the
scrimmage play so whatever the outcome
of that play that's where it goes if you
gain 75 yards and score a touchdown you
score a touchdown if you gain 74 yards
and you're on the one-yard line you've
got the ball on the 1-yard line and
that's why the untime nature this is
critical because it isn't just a way to
avoid the team that takes the lead late
screwing the team that's behind out of a
chance at winning the game think about
this if you're trailing and yeah no
timeouts right right and let's and here
we get let me give you the first example
I thought of yesterday when the untimed
down was officially added to the rule
you're down by 10 points you score a
touchdown with one second left on the
clock yeah and any other game it's over
you're down ten points you're snapping
the ball from the five-yard line with
five seconds on the clock you score the
touchdown hooray you scored a garbage
time touchdown there's no way you're
gonna there's no you have no chance to
win the game well now you do here's why
you make the extra point you're down by
three
there's one second left on the clock you
do the fourth and fifteen play it's an
untimed down you started on your 25 25
yard game gets you to the 50 35 yard
game gets to the 40 if you got one of
these field goal kickers with a big leg
that can make a 57-yard er you only have
to gain 35 yards on the untimed down and
you get the ball on the other team's 40
you don't have to worry about timeouts
or spiking the ball or anything like
that you could throw it right down the
middle of the field and you can get okay
then you kick the field going you force
overtime you score 10 points in 5
seconds ok well let's put our big
noodles together once again then does
that make sense is that fair I don't
know I'm not sure I love that maybe
there needs to be time on those type of
plays to where that doesn't happen I
mean that's a little bit I like it you
like you want to give I want the team
that's trailing to have a chance hey
let's take it to the extreme you can be
down in theory in theory you can be down
16 points with less than 10 seconds
remaining in the game you score and get
the two-point conversion but then even
if there's only one
second left only one second you do the
fourth and 15 play you put the ball on
the other team's 30 you don't have to go
to the throw to the end zone that's the
thing it's no longer a Hail Mary play or
a let's hope Drock is playing deep
safety play and we get a miracle that
way with lateral lateral you get the
bottom 25 and you get it down to the 40
of the 35 of the 30 you get in that
range you have a a plausible shot at
scoring a touchdown you get the other
two pointer voila
16 point deficit gone in less than 10
seconds of clock time I love it okay as
long as you can why I mean one team
dominated it was up by 16 you know 115
dominant enough well let's see the
dominance where this is where we need to
talk about this okay because then it
just like we talk about the team with
the lead now they're gonna kick off and
maybe they can waste time okay we're
gonna make it a ton time down I'm not so
sure that's right either what we're
talking about okay a team's down by 16
they score a touchdown there's one
second left on the clock we're gonna
give them a free a free play no time is
at forty five fifty yards but but they
stay have they still have to do it I
mean if your defense is gonna collapse
to the extent that you allow a team to
cover 75 yards in two snaps one that is
untimed and one that is you deserve to
lose right if you're that good
you're not gonna surrender 75 yards of
field position in one second you're not
gonna do that
so I think there's a fairness to it
there's an equity to it and the goal is
to keep the games close as long as they
can we don't want people checking out of
the games listen but the the point is if
your defense is that good if your team
is that good you are not going to to use
your term crap down your leg in in the
final seconds of the game you got to
finish the job right put them away be up
by 24 points be up by so many points you
got no chance of coming back or put them
away with the game on the line if the
offense can rise up and get that done if
somebody can
laughs 16 points in less than 10 seconds
of clock time and score the touchdown
recover their game the two-point
conversion and then and then put the
ball in position on the untime down to
have a shot at the end zone good for
that guy deserve it's over yet it's got
Patrick mahomes name written all over it
it just says he will never be down the
other side hoping his defense makes the
play I guess
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports